dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly on IFA in this series
we talked a lot about photorealistic
renderings and making sure that the
appearance of our virtual objects is
simulated properly a lot of works on how
things look however in order to create a
more complete sensorial experience we
also have to simulate how these things
sound and today we are going to have a
look at a really cool piece of work
that simulates the sound of virtual
elastic rods
made of aluminum steel oaktree and
rubber and of course before you ask this
also means that there will be sound
simulations of everyone's favorite toy
the walking slinky as for all papers
that have anything to do with something
people I recommend using a pair of
headphones for this episode the sound
emerging from this elastic rod is
particularly difficult to simulate
because of the fact that sound
frequencies vary quite a bit over time
and the objects themselves are also in
motion and subject to deformation during
the simulation and as you will see with
the slinky we potentially have tens of
thousands of contact events in the
meantime let's have a look at some
results
for the fellow scholars who are worried
about the validity of these Star Wars
sounds I know you're up there make sure
to watch the video until the end the
authors of the paper proposed a dipole
model to create this simulation dipoles
are typically used to approximate
electric and magnetic field in physics
and in this case it is really amazing to
see an application of it for sound
synthesis for instance in most cases
these sound waves are typically
symmetric around 2d cross-sections of
these objects which can be described by
a dipole model quite well also it is
computationally quite effective and can
eliminate these lengthy pre-computation
steps that are typically present in
previous techniques there are also
comparisons against the state of the art
and we can hear how much richer the
sound of this new technique is
[Music]
you
and if you know all too well I love all
papers that have something to do with
the real world around us and the reason
for this is that we can try the very
best kind of validation for these
algorithms and this is when we left
reality be our judge some frequency
plots are also available to validate the
output of the algorithm against the real
world sound samples from the lab it is
really amazing to see that we can use
science to breathe more life in our
virtual worlds thanks for watching and
for your generous support now see you
next time
[Music]